germany's new government is starting its
first full day in office with a packed
agenda that includes dealing with a
health system strained by the fourth
wave of the coronavirus pandemic the new
chancellor olaf schultz convened his
three-party cabinet for the first time
on wednesday evening
schultz a social democrat will lead a
17-member cabinet with the
environmentalist green party and the
market friendly free democrats earlier
he took up his post in the chancelley
building when outgoing chancellor angela
merkel officially handed over to her
successor after 16 years in power
schultz served for four years under
meckle as vice chancellor and finance
minister
the mutual respect between the old and
new german leaders was apparent in the
warm words between them and what many
have described as a textbook democratic
handover of power
congratulations to your chancellor dear
olaf shouts
i know from my own experience that it is
a moving occasion to be elected to this
office
as you perhaps can imagine
it is an exciting fulfilling job and a
demanding one but if you approach it
with enthusiasm then it's perhaps one of
the most beautiful jobs there is
to bear responsibility for this country
i sincerely wish you good luck and every
success for our country
i think it's something very special to
be federal chancellor of this republic
it's a great challenge
i'm very grateful that the citizens of
this country and the german bundestag
have given me the mandate to do this
the fact that you and i were able to
share so many experiences together will
help me fulfill my role
thank you again for the work you've done
[Applause]
earlier we spoke to our correspondent
nina haza she sent us this assessment
olaf schwarz's first day in his new
position as germany's new chancellor is
a full one of course he has to deal with
a couple of domestic issues tonight
he'll attend the consultations between
the 16 regional leaders here in germany
who will sit down and discuss the
current and also future possible
anti-covet measures because of course
it's vital also for this new government
to tackle this fourth wave of the corona
pandemic and then there are a couple of
organizational events all of schultz
attends because the handover process
from angela merkel's team to his has to
be completed but today also sees olaf
charles jump onto the international
stage in his new role for the very first
time attending the virtual democracy
summit convened by u.s president joe
biden now olaf schultz is a firm
believer in the idea of multilateralism
and in
jointly fighting authoritarianism and
corruption worldwide he's also promised
to help uphold human rights worldwide
there are a lot of international crises
that give him no time to waste which is
why his first official visits will take
him on friday to paris and brussels
where events on the ukrainian border and
the dispute between the us and russia
are going to be on the table
new foreign minister is in brussels for
the latest stop of her diplomatic tour
on her first day in the job and alina
bairbach is in the belgian capital to
meet with the european union's foreign
policy chief and nato officials she
began the day in paris with her french
counterpart and will later travel to
poland she has promised to take a
tougher line with authoritarian states
ms bierbach told journalists that there
was plenty to discuss ahead of this
weekend's meeting of g7 foreign
ministers
many topics are on the table we have the
situation on the border between belarus
and poland
the current situation
in ukraine
then the further deployment of troops on
the ukrainian border and of course then
on to clarification of the position and
any action europe will take ahead of the
g7 summit
i'm joined now by our brussels bureau
chief alexander von nahman
alexandra it's the first full day in
office for the new foreign minister and
elena barbach she's visited paris
brussels is next what's on her agenda in
the eu capital today
well the first thing on her agenda is a
meeting with eu foreign policy chief
joseph burrell that is taking place
in the building right behind me and we
had a chance to catch up with the german
foreign minister before the meeting and
i asked her
what is the biggest foreign policy
challenge for berlin and for the
european union from her perspective and
she told us that she thinks that it's
very important right now for the
european union to be united and to speak
with one voice when it comes to the many
challenges the block is facing for
example the crisis at the eu's external
border with belarus or
russia's military buildup at the border
with ukraine and that is probably the
topic that
is going to be on the agenda during her
meeting with nato secretary general
general stoltenberg later today
bearbach has already talked about
ensuring that climate change is a
priority what do her counterparts in the
eu expect from her continuity or change
well she had indicated in the past that
she would like germany to take a tougher
stance on russia and china so i can
imagine that her counterparts here in
brussels would like to hear more about
that but overall the signals that
brussels has got from the new german
government are pointing to continuity in
german foreign policy and that is
something that many here will feel
reassured by because of course everyone
knows how big the role is that germany
is playing in the european union and
many are hoping for continuity in german
foreign policy
many thanks alexander that's alexandre
von naaman dw brussels bureau chief